hello we are you look amazing we've been
talking you up I mean a year ago is
where I met you here at the Latin AMAs
here you are you have a huge night ahead
what are you most looking forward to
tonight tonight because I'm 22 years old
and two things that I have lived most of
my life in front of the world social
media just battling through this
industry and and living you know the
highs and lows and in front of the world
it's been quite the journey that's
taught me a lot of things so I think
that's going to be a huge moment for me
tonight that I will know I mean you're
on top of the world Becca G and you're
right it you're really young god only
knows all the things that you're gonna
do you just put out your first album
congratulations
yeah no honestly like it's such a huge
moment for me because like I was
referring to like having done this for
so many years it's a true reflection of
where we are in the music industry that
it's been like a career based off of
singles like that's crazy but that's the
future you know you really figured out
what you wanted to do right and found
getting carved out a space for yourself
in Latin also now you're you're teaming
up and collabing with so many people
including j-hope of BTS what does it
like to have the BTS army on your side
now that was massive thank you no it was
so much fun and it's definitely I think
for me as an artist like to get the
opportunity to like one be inspired and
then learn from a peer like in a way
that you have yet to had experience like
that was huge for me I think it's
definitely gonna be a memory I carry on
my heart food talk about learning from a
peer Jennifer Lopez is gonna be at the
Super Bowl any words for her can we just
have a round of applause for Jennifer
Love is a second
that is HUGE I think
that is for us as a Latino community
it's like something that we should all
be so proud of and also again it's just
like how can you be a reflection of the
audience without really reflecting you
know with the talent who we are and I
think it's something that was long
overdue but is happening at the right
time better late than never right well
we know you got to get in there and get
ready for your big night at performance
congratulation she is so good to see you
congratulations on the album my loss on
thought guys it's gonna drop any minute
now Becky thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]